Is this pace from search for the holy
grail.
The Holy Grail is a myth that was
constructed in Glenndon and the math
goes something like this.
There was a cop,
the grail used to hold Christ's blood
and that cop has a redemptive
significance and it's been lost.
And the night's King Arthur's night to
go off to look for the holy grail or
after this cup.
So it's a redemption story,
right?
It means the world's damned unredeemed.
There's some object that can serve as as
the source of redemption,
the source of nourishment,
say,
thinking about it from a symbolic
perspective,
and it's worthwhile to go on a quest of
that sword.
And the King Arthur's story is set up in
an interesting way because there's a
King Arthur,
but he has all these nights,
these nobles and they all sit at a round
table and they're at a round table
because they're equals.
So although it's a hierarchical story,
there's a motif in it that transcends
the hierarchy.
It says,
well,
yeah,
under normal circumstances,
everyone's in arranged in a hierarchy,
but when you're out to seek whatever you
need,
then everyone's an equal.
And so fine.
So they sit at the round table and then
they go off to search for the holy
grail.
And the story opens with a very
interesting Motif,
which is the nights look at the forest
and then they try to find the part that
looks the darkest to them and then they
go that way.
That's the marker for their mission,
right to go to the darkest place.
And of course each night goes off in a
different direction because the world
looks slightly different to each night.
So objectively speaking they're going to
a different place,
but psychologically speaking they're
going to the same place.
Right in that place I suppose is being
represented in mythology and literature
is the heart of darkness.
And if you're ever curious about why
people aren't enlightened,
since it seems to be a possibility,
you can always think about the story of
King Arthur and the knights of the holy
grail and think,
well do you really want to enter the
forest at the darkest place?
And that's what that is.
Of course.
No,
because the darkest place means
precisely that place you least want to
go.
And it's the same for everyone.
So then I have this little nephew,
although he's almost 15 now,
he had this dream when he was four years
old.
And the background to the dream is this,
he was waking up in the middle of the
night for months screaming,
he had night terrors and this went on
for like six months.
And what was happening in his life was
two fold.
There was some instability in his family
because his parents got divorced about a
year after that.
And also he was at the transition point
from staying at home to going to
kindergarten.
So you know,
not only was he making the big move out
there into the terrible world,
but the stable point from which he might
like to have moved was shaky.
So you know,
he wasn't having that great a time.
So anyways,
he's screaming away at night and this is
pretty unsettling,
right?
Cause night terrors are no joke.
And so he's upset about it.
His mom's upset about it and so I'm
watching him and he's running around the
house.
He's only about this high,
very verbal kid.
And he's got this night hat on in this
sword and the shield and he's running
around the house being a night and at
night he takes his night hack and his
shield and his sword Tibet.
Thank,
oh that's pretty cool.
And you can see how that makes sense,
right?
And you can see how it's an inactive
reality cause children enact or act out
their reality before they can explicitly
understand it just like we do.
And so I'm staying there.
One night he wakes up and he has it,
you know,
one of these fits and then the next
morning it comes to breakfast.
And I said,
hey,
did you have any dreams last night?
And he goes,
yeah,
I had a dream.
I said,
well tell us the dream.
And there's six adults sitting around
the table.
And then he says,
okay,
I,
I was out in this field and I was
surrounded by beat dwarves and they came
up to my knees.
And so these doors,
they had no arms,
they just had shoulders and powerful
legs and they're all covered with hair.
And they had a cross shaved on the top
of their head and they were all covered
with grease.
And everywhere I went these doors would
jump up with their beaks and bite me.
And we're looking at,
I'm like,
that accounts for the night terrors,
right?
And so then he says,
yeah,
and there's more to it too.
If you,
if you looked in the background behind
all the doors,
there was a dragon way in the background
and it was puffing out fire and smoke
and every time it puffed out fire and
smoke a whole bunch more of these
dwarves would get made.
And you think that's pretty cool.
That's a hydra story,
right?
Remember the story of the Hydra,
you cut off one head,
two more grows.
It's one of Hercules,
uh,
trials.
And that's an observation about the
world,
which is you solve one problem and like
two more problems pop up and then you
solve those.
And anyways,
he says,
okay,
well I've got this dragon back there.
And so this is his problem,
right?
He's being eaten by beat dwarves and
that's not good.
And there's not much sense fighting them
off because there's just more of a made
every time this thing lurking in the
background breeds.
So I said,
what could you do about that?
It's like his brain was working all
these ideas around and he'd heard lots
of Disney stories and had lots of books
read to them and had abstracted out a
lot of information,
but he hadn't quite got it right.
And it was all seeding around in his
head.
And I just said,
well what could you do?
Tap.
And he went,
oh,
I know what I could do.
I could take my sword and I'd get my
dad,
which is a good notion,
right?
Cause he's small.
And then I jump up on the dragon and I'd
pop out both of its eyes with the sword
so it couldn't see me.
And then I'd go down its throat to the
box where the fire came out and then I
carve a piece out of the box and I'd use
that as a shield.
And I thought,
great,
you really got the story and the story.
Something like this,
right?
If you're being plagued by midget dwarfs
and you wipe them out and they keep
multiplying while you're obviously
aiming at the wrong target,
right?
You should be going to their source.
So he went after the dragon,
but not only after the dragon,
he went right down the throat of the
Dragon,
which is,
you know,
a fairly brave thing to do.
And then right to the place where the
fire,
the transforming element was being
produced.
And he took a piece of the device that
made the transforming element and he
used it as a shield.
Okay,
well that's really cool.
And the story is better than that I
think.
And it's true even so it's not one of
those fake,
he was dreaming and then woke up sorta
stories.
This actually happened.
He didn't have any more nightmares.
So when I checked with his mother
repeatedly after that,
because I thought,
well,
this is too good to be true,
right?
It's got this terrible night terror
thing.
He does one little mythological dream
thing and bang,
he's,
he's better.
But that's the case.
He didn't have any more nightmares after
that.
And I think that's because he don't
almost already got it right.
He's running around like a night.
He knew almost just had to be made a
little more explicit and not even not
explicit cause it was still a story.
Uh,
he didn't know you should go to the
source of your anxieties,
right to the thing that plagues you the
most.
And you should explore that in detail
until you find the information that it
contains that will protect you against
it.
He couldn't say that,
but he can tell the story and he could
act it out and that looked like it was
good enough.
So that's pretty cool.
So he basically,
you know,
he managed this,
essentially,
he fought the dragon of chaos and pop
back up as what,
as he who can obtain victory over the
dragon of chaos.
And that's a pretty good story because
it says,
well,
if your frame of reference gets blown
away by something you don't understand
some new challenge,
and you face the challenge at least
courageously and humility and humbly,
which means you know you're not gonna
run away on,
you still have something to learn,
then you can extract something out of
the battle that will enable you to
withstand.